this
is star talk i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist
with me is my comedic co-host chuck nice
chuck hey hey neil how are you
still tweeting a nice comic thank you
sir yes i am
having to remind people that you're a
comic well i have to remind myself
that's the problem yeah i'm not worried
about them it's me that i'm concerned
about
you know so uh this is gonna be another
in our
multi-part series on different angles
into the coronavirus and yes
in this particular episode we'll be
addressing coronavirus
conspiracy theories oh my goodness so
we're going to be here for a few days
i'm scared and more broadly skepticism
and science literacy and how do you
invoke that coronavir is just one
example
how we can invoke skepticism but there's
no end
in this list and there's only one person
only one who's the ideal
candidate guest for this and it's the
one and only michael shermer
michael welcome back to star talk that's
right i'm the returning champion
[Laughter]
you're a founding publisher of skeptic
magazine
and a best-selling author uh you've been
our guest on star talk multiple times
and you have a recent book you have
several books in fact if i look
carefully on your shelf
what a coincidence you've got some other
books it's always fun to see what people
put on the shelves behind them
in this uh pandemic era well our most
recent issue as you can see right
there is on conspiracies that was before
the pandemic so it was a good timing
i've never seen the spread like a virus
of conspiracy theories
like this this is really quite crazy and
so in your latest book
giving the devil his due reflections
of a scientific humanist now you have a
book with the word devil in it
why do you do you expect to sell that
book to yeah
there he is yeah you just cut the sails
in half
at least right there well so
yeah but so what what are your main
arguments in there and
why is the devil in the title uh well
the devil is whoever
uh disagrees with you or whoever you
disagree with
whose opinions you dislike anybody uh
whose
uh viewpoint diverges from yours
and the reason those devils should be
given they're due is so that
for your own safety sake that is to say
if you sign off on censorship
and silencing people for voicing their
minority position what happens when
you're in the minority when you're the
lone voice pushing back against the
mainstream when when you want to push
against the dogma
and you've signed off on on silencing
people who disagree
then then they'll come after you so the
title comes from
um a play called a man for all seasons
about
um this is robert bolt's play that was
made into a film
uh about sir thomas more in his
collision with king henry viii
uh over his divorce from catherine of
aragon and the church
you know there's a bunch of different
threads in there but one of which is
um thomas moore arguing with his uh
future son-in-law about uh tearing down
the laws to get after the devil
metaphorically speaking and uh and more
is arguing that we have to give the
devil his due
for our own safety sake that is the laws
are there to protect people
for example the first amendment so if
you say well we got to make an exception
for this one person because he's really
really bad
and he okay well what about this person
because they're really bad also
and you know so you start with something
like you know a conspiracy theorist
extremist like alex jones and you go
okay well we got we have to silence him
and cancel him well what about this this
person over here david ike what about
this guy what about that guy what about
this coronavirus skeptic
well wait a minute maybe the skeptic of
the coronavirus
theory maybe has a point maybe we can
learn something from them
in other words there's a kind of concept
creep or the bin
of which we put stuff in that we think
is dangerous gets larger and larger
so is this it seems to me we've all
heard the phrase
the devil's advocate and if i remember
correctly this was would be in
catholic church trials yeah where
someone
you know you're accused of heresy and
someone would be appointed
by the church to defend you in the face
of the heresy
and of course you're you're on the side
of the devil so we need someone to
defend the devil and devil's advocate
so that was it seems like even though
the whole system was rigged against
it nice to see that this court isn't
biased
i'm already on the side of the devil
as you are prosecuting me for being on
the side of the devil
but but that has an inkling of what
you're saying i think yeah that's right
actually that the position the devil's
advocate the advocate of diable was the
position by the catholic church also to
act as a skeptic
against miracle claims that is to say
everybody and their brother had somebody
they thought should be canonized
and and you have to be you know you have
to i forget it was like two major
miracles and three minor miracles to
begin it's a checklist it's a checklist
it's a checklist
and uh and so the you know and everybody
had a story about
weeping statues and and bleeding
pictures and
miracle cures and things like this so
the catholic church realized that most
of these are bogus so they would appoint
a skeptic essentially someone like
yourself or me to go out there and
investigate and find the natural
explanation
and then it once all those are
eliminated and if there's some left
and they that they could say well that
one is a miracle now you and i would not
go that far of course but
they did centuries ago so the devil's
advocate was actually a valuable
position a skeptical position
yeah yeah so i'm going with the blue oh
blue oyster cult
i'm i'm i'm living i'm living forgiven
the devil is due that's
that's where i come in and i'm burning
i'm burning i'm burning for you
so tell me there's a song in there
okay but you but you you need free
speech
in order to combat conspiracy theories
yeah that's right so um you know here i
kind of are taking so let's bring this
back to coronavirus
so how does this play out does it work
so the reason we need free speech is
because most of us are wrong
much of the time and so the only way to
find out is to listen to what other
people have to say
so the moment you think well we have the
final truth no we don't have the final
we never have the final truths there are
enough
truths with a capital t in science and
the coronavirus is a perfect example of
this there's so many unknowns
and you know although i admire dr fauci
very much he's not omniscient
okay he's not god he may be wrong about
some things and
and the cdc same thing and so forth so
it's good to listen to the people that
are
you know you know kind of pull away from
that or they're you know they disagree a
little bit could be this could be that
is it a bio weapon or is it a you know
genetically engineered virus or is it a
bat virus
well we have the answer to that now but
but it's okay to talk about that because
you know maybe it is this or that
and the things with conspiracy theories
neil is that a lot of them
there's enough of them that are true
that it pays to be
constructively conspiracy that is a
little paranoid
you know and and uh it's not that you
know we think bill gates is going to
take over the world or 5g is causing the
coronavirus but we do know that
pharmaceutical companies have hacked the
you know system of regulations to cheat
the
the standards and make more money we
know volkswagen hacked the
emission standards to make money we know
government agents
uh and politicians lie and and insider
trading and wall street there's enough
these kinds of things that go on
that when someone says you know i'm a
little skeptical about what the cdc said
or what the chinese are telling us
that's not a crazy position to take you
know in other words
enough of it happens that there's a kind
of a logic to listening to some of it at
least
now you sort of go from like 10 percent
away from the fouchy
you know mainstream to 20 to david ike
thinks it's the 5g towers and bill gates
okay but the problem of silencing him
let's say he got kicked off youtube
because he appeared on this british tv
show
a youtube channel wait who got kicked
off
uh this guy named david ike who's who's
sort of the alex jones of england
yeah i mean he's way out there he thinks
you know the lizard aliens are secretly
running the world and all this stuff
okay i mean he is
way out there but you know chuck thinks
that by the way chuck
chuck is totally behind that one they're
they're not they're they're more
amphibians than they are
so i mean sorry i got that wrong don't
don't
hey don't lump me in with the crazies
i'm talking frog people
you know there is a funny story about
that that the 911 truthers are
are uh kind of divided amongst
themselves about
um you know whether there really were
planes or not there's there's an extreme
a group of the truthers who think there
were they're called the no
planers that these were holographic
images that people think they saw planes
but but but it was actually just
explosive devices
and the regular 911 truthers who just
think it was an inside job by the bush
administration
they say oh those no-planers they're
crazy
so yeah it's kind of funny that they
debunk each other
and um and there's splits like that and
creationism and and the flat earthers
are
divided about their arguments and so
it's kind of fun to watch them go at
each other but that's part of the free
speech
let everybody have their voice it'll be
pretty obvious which ones are crazy and
which ones
are not so may i ask this michael um
with respect to health concerns
such as a pandemic there are
consequences to misinformation
and there are consequences to uh for
people who propagate conspiracy
theories to the detriment of the greater
society
how do you deal with that so here's a
person who says
like we shouldn't do a b and c i don't
care what it is let's just say
but but a b and c actually contributes
to the public
good by keeping us all safe from one
another
and mitigating the spread of the disease
what do you do with somebody like that
who is posing an imminent threat
yeah well i agree with you on that um
and
there's a difference between that which
is actual action or behavior that people
take versus the words that they speak
i'm less concerned about the words that
they speak and
but but going out without a mask or
mingling amongst other people when
you're sick
uh you know a lot of americans have this
crazy idea that freedom means i can do
anything i want like there's that viral
video last week of the woman in target
it might have been costco you know
purposely coughing into somebody's face
you know i'm an american and the
constitution says i can do anything i
want no ma'am it does not say that
you know you are not free to drive on
the left side of the road
right you give up that freedom for the
security of
of a safer drive right and just go right
down the line from there there's a
thousand freedoms you give up every
day in the national interests or
security or safety
of your community whatever and you know
the kind of that libertarian notion
uh can go too far i mean the freedom for
you to swing your arm ends at my nose
and the freedom for your kid to cough in
my kid's face when he's got
you know a communicable disease that
that ends up my kids
you know uh health so you know to the
to the anti-vaxxers who say well i
should be free not to vaccinate my kid
well okay maybe but then my kids should
be free from your kids so you can't send
your kid to public schools public
libraries public pools you know don't
let them out
of the house because you know that
that's a risk so
and we we make those kinds of sacrifices
in the interest of
health and safety all the time so the
coronavirus has kind of pushed people on
this
you see these people very confused about
what freedom means
so mike my question is what makes the
coronavirus more susceptible
to conspiracy theorists than some
other thing that might be in the news is
it because we don't have a com
complete and total handle on it and so
that leaves open
uh room for people's imaginations i
think that the cause and effect of this
yeah to to quote one of your heroes
aristotle you know the
the the nature abhors a vacuum the mind
that pours a vacuum of explanation
and we'll fill it with anything we got
and so we we didn't know for a while
what was going on with coronavirus
and you know the novel coronavirus
that's why it was called that it was
novel
you know we'd never seen it before the
origin was you know kind of
um obscure china wasn't exactly
the you know the most honest regime and
trustworthy
regime and and then the cleveland 19
uh pandemic that comes from the
coronavirus then
we weren't sure how fast that was going
to spread and you know in hindsight it's
like yeah we should have closed the
economy
a few weeks earlier like germany did
because look now they're coming out of
it sooner than we are
so forth but nobody knew that that's
with hindsight right we just didn't know
and you know i was there when at that
ted conference when bill gates gave that
famous speech now
seen gone viral on video i think it was
saying this is coming it's the next big
thing and we're all like yeah yeah we've
heard this before you know
the h1n1 and the bird flu and the swine
flu and ebola
and and on and on every couple years
there's one of these things and
everybody says this is it and then it
peters out okay so
it was not completely crazy to think
this might just peter out
right and that but now we go oh okay it
didn't so
that kind of opens the door this is uh
so you have uncertainty a threat a
serious threat a real threat
um and then couple that to a couple
other things that were going on
uh the rollout of 5g at the same time
right so what is 5g well it's an
extension of 4g it's this invisible
force the electromagnetic radiation
i can't see it like nuclear energy i
can't see it smell it taste it touch it
and it's dangerous it's potentially
threatening and
uh and so the 5g thing and then you
throw in there's always a few
way plus 5g was pioneered by the chinese
so that that gave a double force
operating
on the right and the fertility of the
discussion
parenthetically we should note that the
counter factual cities that don't have
5g that have been hit by the coronavirus
and and so forth that it refutes that
hypothesis but nevertheless
uh also another normal driving force
behind conspiracy theory
theories is power differentials so
conspiracy theories are usually targeted
at rich and powerful people
corporations big government agents uh
and agencies
and so forth and so you know here's bill
gates now involved in public health
vaccinations things like this and the
virus and he's rich and powerful
and you know that kind of got lumped in
there with the big companies rolling out
5g
and then big pharma is always in that
formula
right so here they're now being
discussed you know they're going to make
a vaccine
that everybody has to take so they're
going to make a fortune on it and then
bill gates is going to chip
everybody so he can control the world
population
and before you know it you're you know
you're you've gone off the deep end
yeah by the way michael it's not a chip
it's nanites
and uh just like i was wondering how
they're gonna fit them inside the needle
yeah yeah yeah nanobots
that's right nanobots we're gonna take a
break and when we come back we'll
take your questions that have been uh
solicited uh
we were overloaded with skeptics
questions about the coronavirus and
skepticism in general
when we come back on star talk
we're back star talk this is actually a
cosmic queries
edition exploring conspiracy theories
in the coronavers i got checked nice as
always and i don't believe you neil
i don't believe it i don't believe this
is
not exploring conspiracies uh
we've got michael shermer who is the
patron saint
of uh can i say that about you michael
patron of skeptical one more miracle
before i'm sainted
[Laughter]
so with this new book out um give me the
full name
of the devil giving the devil is still
here it is here it is there it is
i mean the devil is due yep uh so
exploring
uh free speech and arguments and the
skeptics movement and how we can apply
that
wisely in our current with our current
challenges
so chuck you got a question for us yeah
we have uh several questions from
our patreon patrons who support us of
course so they lead off this they'll
leave
there's not just patreon for this but we
lead off with our patreon patrons and
we invite you they bought their way to
the front of the list yes
that's just like the titanic
except the titanic sank chuck i hate
everything no that's not a
god that's not a good uh uh noun is it
yeah
okay all right so anyway let's go with
robert colonel who says
uh to assist in the death of conspiracy
theories is it better to confront them
or ignore them has there been any
research on whether confronting these
theories makes it more likely people
will believe them
because of belief reinforcement or
does confronting them give them
credibility and help them spread
wow robert i'm gonna say that's a damn
good question all right michael what do
you got yeah it is kind of
the question of the day well they're
going to spread anyway whether you
ignore them or not
in the modern age everybody is their own
publisher with their own youtube channel
and so on so
that's not a great strategy on the other
hand you're not required to respond to
everybody
uh i mean we ignore the flat earthers
for a long time because you know
the head of it died back in 96 or
whatever and that was the end of that he
was the last member
but then it kind of erupted as you know
neil a couple years ago and
kind of spread went viral so then we
thought all right i guess we need to
have an issue of skeptic
on how we know the earth is not flat and
you know how does science
work anyway and we kind of used it as an
excuse to talk about that but you know
if you ask
the average person how do you know the
earth is round how do you know it goes
around the sun and so forth
a lot of people can't articulate that so
we thought well we'll just use that as
an excuse something like that
we also kind of depends on the influence
that the claim has
the conspiracy theory is are people
talking about it do they care about it
do we need to provide
some kind of response to the media and
the public
and so that also depends so in terms of
free speech you know
uh people should be free to say what
they want but i'm not required to enable
their speech
so you know occasionally creationists or
holocaust deniers have tried to place
ads and skeptic i don't take them
uh but that's not a i'm not censoring
them they're free to publish their own
newsletters and magazines and
produce their own ducks or whatever but
so that's a different kind of thing
there
um so maybe i hope that answers the
question well
you are censoring them in your own
mouthpiece
that's right well in a way though i i
have to be selective we can't talk about
everything
so i i pick the ones i think that are
most important just like college
campuses you know they
they invite maybe 12 public speakers to
come to campus
all right but there's a thousand to
choose from so in a way there that's a
kind of a censorship i suppose
uh that you you you discriminate but
that but they're free to do whatever
they want
all right but but right so i did you i
don't know i don't think you answered
the question
should you directly engage a conspiracy
theorist
on the hope or expectation that you will
change their mind
oh i forgot about that yeah so there was
this idea a few years ago
so-called backfire effect that is by
addressing a particular claim and
explaining why it's wrong like climate
denial denial
uh you'll actually just double the
people will double down on their beliefs
digging their heels yeah digging their
heels now the studies on that have not
been replicated
that is to say it looks like people can
change their mind if you present
evidence in a particular way one in a
very visual way you know pie charts
bar graphs things that are easy to
understand not just piles of numbers
in a in a table but you know something
that's visual and two
you present in a way that that doesn't
challenge the person's
deepest moral beliefs right so the
number
the number one predictor of climate uh
skepticism is political position
so uh but but climate skeptics who are
tend to be conservative they don't know
anything more about climate science than
than the climatic believers say
democrats or liberals
that is to say knowledge about climate
science does not predict who
believes in it or accepts it so the
public expression of your skepticism or
belief is more of a
signal to your tribe i'm so conservative
i doubt that climate science business
right
even if you don't know anything about it
same thing with evolution you know and
uh if you give people if you give
christians a choice between darwin and
jesus
they're not picking darwin okay darwin
is not going to be anybody's savior
right so you have to take that off the
table keep keep your savior keep jesus
keep your christianity
evolution was the way god created life
for something like this and then you
take that off the table
so they don't feel threatened so those
are the two things you can
do to get around the backfire effect so
the tactics this is tactical
yeah strategy yeah okay all right so
chuck what else you got okay uh this one
is from
um who is this guy chuck nice co-host of
star talk radio
are you a patreon member indeed i am
okay um has there been any studies done
on the
psychological makeup of people who are
prone to believe in conspiracy theories
yeah there's a fair amount of research
on that now first of all the
the meme we hear of you know the
conspiracy theorists is some overweight
guy in his
parents bedroom you know with a tin foil
hat
and an internet connection uh you know
that
that's not the case really most
conspiracy theorists are thoughtful
educated and so on
it depends on the conspiracy theory
right so
um say politically those that are in
power tend to be less conspiratorially
minded than those out of power so the
losing party usually
goes goes conspiracy bonkers after they
lose
those in power drop the conspiracy
theories now the current administration
president seems to be an exception to
that he's still talking about the
conspiracy against him in the election
it's like dude you won
shut up
oh it was rigged it's like uh you know
you won right
so but there but there are some things
uh
you know like what's called global
coherence that is the moment you tick
the box for believing one conspiracy
theory
uh that you think princess diana was
assassinated you're more likely to
believe that jfk was
assassinated by a conspiracy and or in
any
number of the other popular 911 was an
inside job and
and so forth that that there's sort of a
a tendency to to think
somebody is behind the scenes pulling
the strings and the moment you sort of
go down that pathway
you think it happens everywhere even
within a particular conspiracy theory
that is people that
are more likely to check the box that
they think princess diana
was murdered are also more likely to
think she faked her death and is still
alive somewhere
well that can't be they can't both be
true she can't be dead and alive at the
same time right
so uh and so and also there's a bias
that some people are more inclined to
that is the size the size of the cause
should match the size of the effect
you know so the holocaust was the worst
thing ever happened to a group of people
committed by
the nazis the worst regime in history so
you sort of get this match
right but jfk leader of the free world
and the most powerful man on earth
assassinated by who lee harvey oswald
some lone nut you know it doesn't match
so you got to add
the fbi and the cia and the kgb and the
cubans and the mafia
you know to kind of make it match same
thing with princess die you know
cause of death drunk driving speeding no
seat belt you know tens of thousands of
people die of that every year but
princesses are not supposed to tie like
that
right so you gotta have the mi5 and the
mi6 and the royal family and the arabs
and
we're all in on it and so 19 members of
you know 19 guys with box cutters you
know brought down the world trade center
building that i mean come on that's just
that you know bush had to be involved in
this group and that group so you get
some of that and some people are more
inclined toward that kind of
reasoning than others is it because deep
in our minds we we want
a full explanation for there's there's a
need
that's being served but a psychological
need being served by
the flesh that's on a conspiracy theory
exactly right and and even scarier
is the idea that nobody's in charge you
know the idea that
there's a cigarette smoking man behind
the curtain and he's making
all these things happen wars and
economic revolutions and so on
uh but the idea that actually there's
nobody that
runs the economy the economy is just
this sort of chaotic
unpredictable thing that's kind of scary
in a way
uh wait i gotta wait i got a question
michael okay
isn't god the ultimate conspiracy
theorist i mean people who believe in
god that's the ultimate conspiracy
god is in charge of all things so here's
the question are
religious people if they're satisfied
that god
is operating do they have any more or
less susceptibility to
other understandings of the world with
regard to conspiracy
i i haven't seen any data on that that
religiosity is a predictor of conspiracy
mindedness or the or not or the opposite
of the opposite religious people are
less correct if i'm wrong
are less represented among astrologers
and other sort of
yes um um new age uh
yes that would be good that that may be
a good study for our research
uh team at okay we'll get to it get to
it i'm gonna
i'm gonna do this the moment we hang up
here but let's actually
neil you got me thinking there uh in a
way i mean um the the common
line that religious people use is
everything happens for a reason
now it's not just christians i mean
there's a lot of like deepak
chopra following buddhist western
buddhists that think you know there's
some kind of
cosmic force that balances things and if
something bad happens over here
something good happens over there
that's the ultimate conspiracy theory
that that is a kind of conspiracy theory
yeah i hadn't really thought of it that
way
yeah it's interesting wow chuck give me
give me some more
all right here we go um this is alan
demoss
says first of all i love the show my
question is where is the healthy line
between believing in some grand
conspiracy and being a very cautious
skeptic and is this
is it for some not for you of course or
or neil but is it for some perhaps
the beginning of the slippery slope i
start off as a skeptic and then before
you know it i don't believe anything
this is
all bs
yeah carl sagan had a great line that i
i quoted in my first book why people
believe were things on
the the kind of healthy skepticism that
finding the rub between being
open-minded enough to accept radical new
ideas but not so open-minded that your
brains fall out
and you believe every wacky thing that
comes down the pike and it's
hard to know where that line is
essentially the line of demarcation
between science and pseudoscience say
and it depends on the particular area so
since we're talking about conspiracy
theories
you know the bigger it is the grander it
is the less likely the theory is to be
true
again conspiracies like volkswagen
cheating the emission standards or
pharmaceutical companies cheating the
fda regulations
you know those are real conspiracy but
they're very narrow and targeted like we
know why they're doing it to make money
you know in this one little area you
know but the moment you scale up you
know
world domination it's like okay you know
probably not no but you need the cubans
and the chinese and the north koreans
just keep adding them in there right you
got nothing
that's right and the more people that
have to be involved right because
people's people are fairly incompetent
and they bumble and stumble their way
through jobs and
you know the idea that you know you've
you've cracked the perfect team to go
out there and pull this off i mean
nixon had a pretty good team of you know
the watergate burglars right i mean
these were g-men
you know g gordon liddy i mean come on
and they couldn't even
burgle an office without getting caught
right
that's kind of how things normally go
the more elements
now now a billion photos are uplifted to
the internet every day
you'd have pictures of stuff even even
you know the stockpiled aliens in area
somebody's sneaking a photo out on their
instagram you know
that's right actually i i use the
wikileaks as an example of the absence
of evidence is evidence of absence
that is to say uh you know the
ufologists
or the 911 truthers would always say
well of course we don't have direct
evidence shurmur it's a secret
it's classified you know and it's like
okay
here we have 10 million documents that
are classified
leaked by wikileaks there's nothing in
there about roswell
alien bodies at area 51 you know some
memo from bush telling somebody to plant
the explosive devices in the world trade
center bill
makes sense wow what it is we're going
to take another break and when we come
back our third and final segment
conspiracy in the coronavers on star
talk
we're back star talk chuck nice michael
shermer
mike i've known you for okay i've known
you for a really long time i'm just
pleased to have this friendship that
goes back decades
uh that we're we're kind of fighting
for the same causes but differently i
mean i'm not in your face
because i know you don't need me you you
you're your face you got this
i just want you to know that i'm a huge
supporter
of your work and your life's direction
that you've taken it so just want to put
that well thank you i i appreciate that
uh
operators are standing by to take your
uh your donation just kidding
so chuck give me some really
it takes all of us working on this
together you know right
scientists from all fields pushing back
in their areas
you know all we are is kind of a
collective body that says
here's all the different uh claims and
here's the experts in that
you know so we're all you know working
to the same really enlightenment idea
that there is a truth to be known
truth of the small t and that science is
the best tool we have to get there
nice all right check keep it going all
right
uh let's go to maddalena grouper
and magdalena says thank you for
sparking
joy and curiosity of science in my 40s
um could you please tell me how to sell
the idea of skepticism to people
successfully
to get them excited about being
skeptical
i find it immensely hard not to sound
condescending or sarcastic
when i try well matt delano maybe it's
you
[Laughter]
no but michael you got you got to admit
there are a lot of skeptics in the
community
that are just [ __ ] and they're
it's like i'm no more than you i mean as
an educator it hurts me to watch that
exchange
because i i want i care what someone
knows and doesn't know and i
find you know ways that
that i can communicate not just
talk down to them and you know such
folks are in the skeptics community
what do you do about that yes well
um you tell them don't be a dick
but even that well that that was the
title of a
of a speech given by our friend and
colleague
uh the bad astronomer yeah phil plate
yeah that's right okay we'll hold speech
don't be a dick
yeah and i think that i think that was
fairly well
received although i know he got some
push back but carl made that point back
in the 90s
i think it was a passage maybe from
demon haunted world where he
uh he said something like it's easy to
be condescending to people i
i feel the urge myself bubble up and i
have to kind of suppress it we should
all suppress it
and just talk about you know the
positive aspects of what we know
acknowledge that the other person uh you
know is intelligent
thoughtful or else they're not gonna
listen to you you know be respectful
there's certain kind of basic rules of
engagement or conversation and by the
way
that point of view is deeply imbued
within andrewian
who was co-writer of all three cosmoses
so that at every turn we were to talk
about
um some crazy idea that people have
the urge to just say this is just
preposterous that urge is so
strong yeah but but then you know you
can't and shouldn't go there otherwise
you just lost your audience
so you've got to find a way that it sort
of organically
reaches them so that they feel like that
you care about
who they are and how they think and
where they came from and that you're
going to take them to a new place
yeah that's right i'm fine to say no one
in the history of the world has ever
joined a cult
you know they join a group that they
think is good and they just get sucked
down the rabbit hole and that you know
only outsiders can kind of assess that
but if you tell people you know you're
in a cult
you know that's not what they think is
going on and analogously i say no one's
ever
no in the history of the world has never
been a pseudo-scientist who goes down to
a pseudo lab to collect pseudo-facts to
test the pseudo theory
right you know they think they're doing
something and so you have to address it
at that level
like you know what why is it you think
that that's the case i'm i know you get
these theory what i call theories of
everything you know einstein was wrong
and newton was wrong and
hawking was wrong and i've worked out
this new theory of the universe in my
garage
you know okay you can't just say you
know what you're the 20th crazy person
this week to send me
one of these uh because you know that's
just hurts their they don't think that
that's
what they're doing so you have to at
least listen
i mean if you're gonna engage with them
you know the rules of conversation
listen to what somebody has to say let
them finish their sentence
see if you can repeat back to them what
they just said you know the the kind of
steel manning rather than straw manning
you know say it in a way that they would
go yeah yeah that is what i'm arguing or
they're more likely to go no no no that
that's not quite what i mean what i mean
is now maybe they did mean that and they
realized how
nutty it sounds when you say it so they
correct it but that's also good
right conversation is about adjusting
our ideas and exchanging ideas and so on
so
and i was honored michael that you had
invited me onto your podcast
for my last book which was letters from
an astrophysicist
about a third of them are i'm carefully
uh
communicating with some of them were
conspiracy theorists there's a flat
earther in there and a
bigfoot person and and so i i was i i
was honored that you
saw that in me enough to have me as a
guest on your podcast oh yeah no that's
uh that kind of exchange i think is
super fascinating i
i love getting those kind of letters
because it's it's interesting to engage
with them
and and just ask them what how did you
come to this belief or
what makes you think that's true or what
would what would it take to change your
mind
you know and it's just super interesting
to think about the psychology of why
people
believe what they believe and that's
different from say refuting their
arguments or whatever those are kind of
two different levels
all right chuck what else you got okay
uh back to our corona
uh our coronavers that we live in josh
v says to mask or not to mask
that is the question why did the cdc
change their advice about mass halfway
through the pandemic
does this type of flip-flop fuel
conspiracy theories or at least
increase distrust in authority
nice one yeah yeah it certainly can i
remember when that happened
part of the reason they were saying no
masks was at first they were
worried about the supply chain for
healthcare workers to have enough masks
and if everybody
made a run on mass there wouldn't be
enough for the healthcare workers i
think that was the first reason
you know because i remember it as well
yeah they kind of masked it by saying
well
maybe you don't need it and then this
the science changed i don't think the
science ever really changed i think it
was more of a supply chain concern
um and you know we're still again here
we are
that they were recording we still don't
know 100 about you know how many feet
should you be apart from you know six
feet where they come up with that number
maybe it's seven maybe it's three who
knows
you know still a lot of that so we're
you know there's going to be a lot of
hindsight bias in the next
say decade of you know pundits uh uh
second guessing everything we did you
know i saw some numbers today
on germany it looks like they they they
timed it just about right of when to
shut down the economy and
they're starting to reopen now but
they're all experiments different
nations trying different things
different states within
the united states trying different
things this is good you know
experimentation is how we get to the
truth
yeah but that's not the the
fluctuating frontier
of what is experimentally true
is not something that's taught in school
you think of science as a known
thing and if a scientist says something
different tomorrow than today
all of a sudden people feel justified to
discount the entire source
of this information yeah the whole
source gets cancelled
right that's right yeah yeah the problem
with teaching justif
science is just a body of facts is too
delimiting it's really a method
it's just a way of asking questions
about the world and seeing what kind of
answers you can get that are reliable
so if we were to perhaps um just
adjust the perspective uh
behind what the way we're teaching
science
and the way it's received more
importantly
focus more on discovery yeah yeah
see if it's about if it's all about
discovery
then it's okay for things to change
we've discovered
like for instance we thought it was all
about surfaces
we now discovered that it is not that
yeah you still got to be concerned about
surfaces but we also now must be equally
concerned
about our exchange with one another uh
when it comes to speaking and being in
our presence and
and distancing so but i think what
happens is that this
definitive and these declarative nature
of of arguments being made is what
causes people to go well then you don't
know what the hell you talking about
way out i'm not listen you don't know
what the hell are you talking about
chuck for surgeon general
yeah that's right uh it would be better
if we thought of failures
as actual successes you know we
succeeded in finding out
the cause of it is not this this this
this those are successes actually
and this is the this is the famous
mantra in in
space exploration it's if a rocket
explodes on the launch pad
and you say it's a failure no it is an
experiment
rich in data for the next experiment
that's funny i mean not that the rocket
blew up that's not funny
no no no no the richard data parties
could be
right right chuck time for like maybe
one or two more
okay all right here we go all right uh
this is jessica bennett and she wants to
know who is controlling the massive
amount of twitter bots
that are pushing for no mass and pushing
to reopen america uh that's something i
didn't know about but
is that a we should ask uh jack
about that the guy that runs oh yeah
jack dorsey yeah
yeah because what do i know i mean maybe
they're russian bots or chinese bots or
whatever
i'm encouraged by some recent research
by hugo mercier the cognitive scientist
uh about the influence of those kind of
bots
on say the 2016 election he thinks that
the influence was negligible if at all
that people were pretty already pretty
much already made up their minds
you know and and you know the the funny
story is you know that if if you think
hillary is running a
pedophile ring out of a pizzeria and i
correct you on that you're not likely to
vote for hillary
you know you're you're probably inclined
to kind of not
be a big fan of hers anyway she's like
oh she's not selling babies i'll go for
now exactly
all right did we answer that question
what's the next one what's the next one
uh yeah here's the next one
um spin bourne sven bjorn bird
wants to know this i've had that we've
had these questions before
oh yes back again
uh and why aren't you telling me where
the what platforms these are coming from
ah
giving out that information it's not
here so
okay okay so how can you say theories
are conspiracies
if china is not being transparent
so you know and i think this is
this is really emblematic of a big
problem
and that is you have one fact
that actually leads and supports a
conspiracy
but then that mushrooms into like these
thousands of things that are attached to
it
yeah that's right so this is the problem
with authoritarian regimes not being up
front
uh they may be transparent and honest
now but how do we know because they've
lied so many times it's
a little bit like that that's why it's
called the chernobyl of china you know
that because we know the soviets were
you know took him like i don't know a
week and a half
uh and until radiation started falling
over sweden and norway that they said uh
well i guess we you know should be more
upfront about what actually happened at
chernobyl
uh that's the problem so if you lie and
then you say well this time i'm telling
the truth
you know how do we know that fuels
conspiracism of course because
that's part of conspiracy theories is
that somebody is behind the scenes doing
something wrong
and of course they're going to lie about
it that's true
so there's a good reason to be skeptical
or
or conspiratorial so but what it means
is in the case of china
then even if like you said even if they
are telling the truth
you don't know even if that is true
because there's the room that it could
be
a lie or a false interest false
information you know disinformation
right yeah well in the words of xi
jinping
you can't handle the truth
was that who said that i was wondering
where that came from sure
i'm pretty sure it was see
[Laughter]
so uh mike i want to spend the last
couple of minutes could you give me some
of the more outlandish by your judgment
conspiracy
theories regarding the coronavirus i
mean like top three
yeah top well like you know 5g bill
gates
uh bio weapon is bioweapon is not quite
as crazy but but we now know from the
genetic analysis that it was
not engineered it's a bat virus um
you know that uh you know the of course
the the anti-vaxxers were all over this
very predictable they jump on anything
like this
we've been tracking them for a quarter
century every time something like this
happens
there's the anti-vaxxers and uh so that
you know that
that's not great just crazy it's
dangerous because
you know vaccines are one of the best
things we've ever invented
for saving human lives and uh you know
so that that's a disturbing one not just
crazy but
but but but dangerous what do what would
anti-vectors say
oh that um that the either the
government you know or the
pharmaceutical companies big pharma
are using the coronavirus pandemic
as a scare tactic to force people to
vaccinate
and then from there you go to their
they're going to chip us all so they can
track us
uh or nanobot us and then track us
you know even the tracking and tracing
you know
you know this this idea is is part of
that
kind of new world order conspiracy
theory that goes back to the 1980s
and in a way if you think about it uh
you know we are all being tracked we are
already chipped you have a smartphone in
your pocket that has chips in it and
somebody knows where you are and uh and
maybe who you're talking to and where
you're shopping and so on and so forth
in a way this has kind of happened but
we voluntarily
did it and it's not big pharma and it's
not big government it's uh you know big
tech
walked right into it and then uh what
about the
conspiracy that it was maybe it's not a
conspiracy or cover-up
that it was a lab leaked
yeah so uh you know uh nature
uh nature medicine journal published uh
the genome
analysis of the uh novel coronavirus and
that
it is like 98.5 similar to a bat
corona virus remember coronaviruses are
very common you know a third of all
common colds are coronaviruses the
others are
rhinoviruses and one other you know it
makes sense bats live
bats are mammals they're very uh
susceptible to respiratory diseases
they live in giant populations there's
this cave in texas
with like 20 million members like it's
the city of mexico
and you know they get these kind of
pandemic spreads all the time so
it kind of makes sense wet market in
china you know
wait so bats bats don't social distance
when they they
don't they they hang upside down right
next to each other
that's what makes it kind of spooky
they're making a cute comic batch social
distancing
[Laughter]
i don't want to get a human virus
wash your wings for 20 seconds
but but it is true that the uh wuhan is
the site of a infectious disease
research center that's right
and there are bioweapons labs around the
world and you know
twice under during the cold war the
russian bile
weapons labs had a leak one was i think
a fire and the other one was an
accidental leak
uh and so you know it's again it's not
completely crazy to ask the question or
to explore the idea
but i think that one's answered now so
chuck michael
we are out of time but this has been
highly illuminating michael it's always
great to talk to you and your new book i
think just released
just in time for the coronavirus because
you knew you were planning this in fact
you're the one who closed the camera and
as soon as we hang up i'm going back
into my bio weapons lab
[Laughter]
giving the devil his due reflections uh
of a scientific humanist which you are
so
uh michael always good to have you uh
don't be a stranger
jack i love you man i love you too man
yeah all right gentlemen
thank you this has been star talk cosmic
queries
yet another coronavirus edition this one
on conspiracy theories as always i bid
you
to keep looking up